good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday turdy says it's Friday
dirty says it's Friday and so does the
calendar it's a beautiful day we made it
to the weekend the holiday weekend I
know this feels so good feels so good
everyone feels so good and also quite a
little fun fact about you and I today is
that we are both wearing rails oh man
you're wearing rails too yeah my
sweaters were ales well it's a little
chilly in New York it's raining two days
in a row uh it feels personal it feels
personal that's sweet
no it feels personal Theo got groomed
yesterday the second his grooming was
over rain rain oh they're coming for
Theo it feels personal it feels targeted
it isn't it always
isn't it always isn't someone always
targeting you turdy uh actually yeah and
we're gonna we're gonna get into that
later in the show about me being
targeted yeah turdy's under attack I'm
under attack I'm under attack
today's headline turd under attack
let her relay you I don't know why ever
since I kind of became the turdy people
are so jealous of me oh my God they're
obsessed and everyone wants to be the
turd but they're all irrelevant uglies
and I am the actual turd the one the
only turd I did a q a yesterday and
someone was like have you ever thought
about getting your gums fixed and like I
think they were trolling me
um because like don't get me wrong I
have a laundry list of insecurities my
gums are not one of them and like I
think maybe she was trying to create an
insecurity for me but it didn't work
because I have like just say what you
want maybe I got a little bit buck teeth
I got fangs I don't have gum issues
[__] no that's always crazy when people
like say something and it's like oh I
know I literally have been in this body
for 30 years and I never realized that
that was wrong with me no but it's
actually like I like there's fact and
reality and the reality and the facts
are I don't have gum problems I have a
million other issues I had moles you
know I've got a back problem I've
struggled with my weight my whole life
uh yeah my gums ain't one of my issues
yeah or are they let me see them [__]
okay ready smile
I've never thought you to be
particularly gummy if anything you know
it's been a really long time since I've
gotten lip filler and actually in the
last like week when I've been looking at
the podcast or just pictures of myself
I'm like damn I need to get my lips
filled so maybe like she this girl was
just like seeing the come down of my
lips maybe
I love when you get lip filler I think
it's really important I love getting lip
filler too I just don't like the first
couple of days when you're really
swollen like you feel like that's how
it's going to be forever and I just
don't like I look like a little crazy
the first week and then it really
settles and and does a nice job because
I don't do a lot but that first couple
of days I'm like oh my God what did I do
and like I know it's gonna go down so
dirty even when you get a haircut and a
trip what did I do so today that's so so
turdy it's the change that she can't
stand it's so true
it's so true
you just read me to fail you read me
like a book not to failed I just read
you yeah no like like a book like a book
speaking of books I finally finished
that [__] book I've been reading for
three weeks the marriage portrait which
Dana recommended which is actually like
on a list and it's very Buzzy so I just
want to let you guys know like if you're
seeing it and you're thinking it's
something you should read like if you
usually identify with my taste don't do
it oh my God it like was so Claudia like
I can't think of a book you would hate
more it was so descriptive there would
be whole pages that didn't have like a
paragraph indentation do you know what I
mean by that like oh not a quote Nary a
break like they're describing Luke crazy
as dreams and it's not as if the dreams
are germane to the story like it was not
my favorite 2.5 stars for me looking
forward to moving on
I'm so glad you got over that hump and
it wasn't even hump day yeah and I kept
pushing forward you're like Jax why did
you read it like you know you could have
given up at week one I kept pushing
forward because Dana said like I trust
Dana truly but then it turns out she
said one you could give up now because
the whole book is kind of the same it
doesn't get like much different or
better she was like two I only
recommended it to you because like this
is your beat and I like read something
historical royalty so I thought you
would like it
so what you're saying is that Dana can't
be trusted what I'm saying is is that I
just next time she recommends something
to me I'm gonna say why are you
recommending this book to me yeah what
is the reason because you think I would
like it or because you liked it what was
the reason
yeah what was the reason
so I'm feeling good about that and I'm
feeling good you're also I know why
you're feeling good because yesterday's
episode inspired you to actually book a
staycation right it did I'm going on a
staycation this weekend and I'm so
excited like not only I'm excited for
the staycation but this excitement that
in the days leading up now that I've had
just like talking about going to the
beach with my boys and like
I'm really so excited I didn't realize
how much I needed like a little vacation
a little reprieve so and just a station
and you live in Florida like a
staycation it's like not sad you know no
with staycation in Florida is like a
real vacation right except it's
literally gonna be like a five minute
staycation but still right no I'm happy
for you I love that Journey for you
mm-hmm
and I'm jealous if I'm if I'm if in the
name of honesty attorney should be there
I think like you would really love it
um turdy should be there we are going to
the beach
we'll go to dinner I'm excited
and like the fact that I'm missing like
I've been there for so many of Harry's
first and I'm missing Harry's first time
at the beach it's disgusting it's
anti-neglect is what it is and it's
Bruno's first time at the beach
Bruno deserves the world he does such a
good brother he's such a good brother
it's crazy and he's really kind of taken
you know the he used to be in the
driver's seat you know Mommy and Daddy's
number one boy now he's in the passenger
seat and he's taken it with stride I
think a lot of other dogs might have had
the pride issue not Bruno he knows his
place no but he takes it out on Theo
yeah because he says listen I will
always be number two to the little boy I
understand he has needs but Theo do not
touch my mommy
without me there so true
he's human after all what can we do like
our boys just love us so much and it's
like it's overwhelming
it is it's overwhelming to be loved so
dearly dearly dearly dearly clearly the
way turd has taken on a life of its own
I was looking yesterday when I was in LA
I did like these little cute content
video shoots with deer media and they've
solely started to post them over the
last couple weeks and the most recent
one went up like yesterday or the day
before on their Instagram the comments
oh turd we love our turd mcternia like
it is insane and even in my q a
yesterday someone was like do you like
let's be real like just be honest with
us do you dislike like being known by
turd and like no it really is a term of
endearment I would be honest if
something bothered me yeah you would be
I feel like I don't know if I could
handle
being called like the turd all the time
um but it is like a really cute name
when you think about it no and like when
I see somebody Jamie like hey turd I
don't automatically think hey feces like
I don't do you know you know what it's
just like the snitch like she's not a
snitch right but she's right the snitch
right right right right right so I'm
loving it just wanted to unburden myself
and speaking of we had a episode drop
yesterday Jackie and I for those who
remember our unburdened yourselves
segment here at the toasty spear weekly
segment didn't really work for The Daily
Show but we started to do it in monthly
installations read your segment be like
oh that sucks and move on like now we
can really go in dive deep on every
submission and it's so fun and it was
like two days before dear toasters and
it was like a little too similar to Deer
toasters yeah
um so it just wasn't right but like the
segment itself really was a fabulous
idea so it's up on our patreon now it's
like a monthly thing we did a video and
audio episode and it was Fab fabulous
and I made a joke at the end that I
thought was so funny I made Ben watch it
like I might
my my smile joke you know like smile no
yeah I don't want to spoil it by saying
give me more context like what were you
talking about smile
like this girl in the front row smile oh
my God it's so funny oh my God I got
home I literally was a bit was like how
was your day I'm like I made a joke that
was so funny and I made him listen to it
and he cackled too I was like really
proud of my joke you know yeah and I was
proud of the script that I developed for
a romantic comedy
um inspired by one of our submissions
inspired by one of our submissions like
I need to see this movie I'm waiting for
James Cameron to call me because I have
like a laundry list of things to tell
him and I will be added to the list I'll
be adding that to the list love that for
you starring Maybe
starring turdy
or maybe starring me yeah put yourself
first Jax it's your film yeah like maybe
I could be the writer and director kind
of like Kelsea ballerini Jackie I was
about to use that Segway as well Jackie
and I both this morning watched uh
Kelsea ballerini's short film we're
going to talk about that because she's
in the news SNL traps Kelsey yeah yeah
that's what spurred me watching it
because I wanted to talk about how she's
gonna be on SNL but it's like if I
haven't listened to the music like what
am I gonna say and so many people in our
comments have been like you guys have to
see this and I feel like it really has
this like Grassroots movement movement
because I haven't seen I mean I checked
the news every day I haven't really seen
like a lot of any headlines about it
and I'm sure if you search her on Google
they come up but like they weren't on
like home pages and stuff and even the
video the short film on YouTube like
doesn't doesn't have a million views yet
like I feel like it's gaining steam it's
giving kind of like Olivia Rodrigo yeah
like very
um like like the consumers are gonna
make this yeah because I mean you like
listen to it it's just like really good
quality you know and yeah EP that feels
like a real EP it was extremely well
done so we're going to talk about it in
our story about Kelsey it's kind of like
the year of Kelsey she's been like
everywhere yeah and she'll be on SNL so
let's get into the stories yeah yeah you
can start off with that and I'll move
some things around we'll start about
that without further Ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before the holiday weekend
you guys
and today's episode is sponsored by
Better Health when you're at your best
you can do great things but sometimes
life gets you bogged down and you may
feel overwhelmed or like you're not
showing up in the way that you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you if you've been thinking
about giving therapy a try it can be
kind of overwhelming a lot of people
don't know where to start better help is
a really great place to start it is
convenient it's flexible it's affordable
and it's all done entirely online just
fill out a brief questionnaire and
you'll get matched with a licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge I
think a lot of people who are in therapy
will tell you it's super normal to like
shop around for a therapist before you
find one that's right for you because
you really need to match with them on
like a compatibility level and better
help makes it super easy it's not
awkward enough to go to like waiting
rooms it's also really affordable again
it's all done online so you can call you
can video you can text with your
therapist whenever you need them and
it's just a really great
um it's a great resource for a lot of
people so if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com toast to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
Health
toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t there's really never been a
better time to start taking care of you
it's like you know Leslie Mann said and
this is 40. oh no not this is 40. The
Other Woman
brain camp you know you go to the gym
for your body go to therapy for your
brain start taking care of you today
today's episode is also brought to you
by stamps.com 2023 is underway do not
wait any longer to level up your small
business and set yourself up for Success
get ahead of the competition by using
stamps.com to mail and ship just a quick
shout out to stamps.com we've been using
them for many many years they've been a
sponsor of our show for many many years
they are a fabulous brand because they
ensure that everything is easy because
life is so hard and stamps.com agrees
said it shouldn't be that way so whether
you run a small business you have a lot
of shipping needs just do everything
from your at-home computer print
shipping labels uh you can also get
discounts from USPS and UPS from
stamps.com it's just like literally a
no-brainer I don't know why anyone
wouldn't so you can set your business up
for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
toast for a special offer that includes
a four week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code turst no
I'm kidding it's code toast toast I have
to stop doing that I know but it's
really hard it's it's literally
impossible are you ready for our first
story yes SNL has announced three weeks
of SNL lineups February 25th Woody
Harrelson and the Jack White March 4th
Travis Kelsey and Kelsey ballerini and
then March 11th Jenna Ortega and the
1975. so of course we're very hyper
focused on the Kelsey of it all even
though the third one is huge because
like Jenna Ortega is having this moment
and of course the 1975 is like yeah
that'll be a big one too yeah but Travis
Kelsey is the man of the week and he's
hosting SNL which is like kind of crazy
it is kind of crazy because he's not a
like certain like the Manning brothers
have done it JJ Watt has done it people
have done it but I feel like they're
usually quarterbacks uh
uh I don't know if JJ Watts a
quarterback yeah no he's not
but like I don't know I feel like the
stars of the football like
um teams are always the quarterbacks
like we always know the quarterback's
names yeah I I don't know I feel like he
has that person out like he's really
he's always had this personality I feel
like because the Super Bowl and the
Kelsey bull like he's someone that we're
kind of fixating on he kind of reminds
me of Gronk like yeah yeah yeah and but
he just is that guy like he doesn't have
to put on and I I wonder if the Eagles
had won like if Jason would be getting
these opportunities so that was my
thought as well like when I saw that he
was announced my initial reaction was
like oh great and then I was like wait
what about Jason and I'm sure that Jason
will be in a sketch and I'm sure he'll
be there with the mom too like I know
it'll really will be a family affair
because they're like you know brothers
who support Brothers but I I did think
like oh well it's because he lost even
though like Travis is just more of like
a forward-facing selection I know but I
feel like him before if Travis lost he
wouldn't be doing not that like it's
like oh you lost you can't do it but
it's like because he won he's like on
the tour and yeah I don't know who's on
Jimmy Fallon last night yeah so I just I
wonder how things would have played out
if Jason had one it literally doesn't
matter I think Travis will be great I'm
glad that he's getting his shine you
know he's clearly not afraid of the
spotlight he did his show yeah and I
think this is really sweet and the world
gets to continue its obsession with the
Kelsey Brethren and by the world I mean
us can I say something that might be
like a hot take sure
I think a lot of it's like overexposure
to Travis Kelsey for me is like it's
giving me a little bit of like the ick
Howard do you feel Overexposed like it's
just like a lot and I feel like he's
loving it and like leaning in like a
little too much I can't explain it it's
just like with Jason it feels so like
authentic
I was like Travis it feels like a little
forced I can't explain it and I have no
reason and I I can't explain it further
but like aside from Fallon and SNL like
what has he done that Jason hasn't they
just do the podcast and they played in
the game no like if you look at his
social media I feel like he's like
playing on like the Kelsey ball like a
little more he's like leaning in a lot
oh my God but the day of the Super Bowl
posting like a montage of like childhood
photos of him and his brother which I'm
sure was really genuine and sweet I I
just I don't know something about it am
I the only one I'm just like all right
like it's a lot you know like and I want
more Jason I want more juice I want more
Jason but also like Travis is a lot and
like there's always been this way so now
he has this like huge Spotlight and it's
like it's only going to be more than
that no I know but like you know even
and I talked about this after the Super
Bowl like his post game interview he was
just like talking yeah over everyone and
the dancing like he's just starting to
like kind of be a lot for me you were
feeling that way yeah I feel like he's
the right amount for who he is and and
this moment for him I feel yeah I I know
that they will but I really do hope hope
they include you know the other brother
and Jason and the the parents like and I
know they will because it's been it
really hasn't even been about Travis
it's been about the Kelsey's yeah and
they are hosting March 4th so I think
that gives enough time for um Kylie to
have her baby I don't think she's had
her baby yet or if she has like she just
had it and they haven't announced it
um so I think Jason could maybe make the
trip up to New York like it's not right
yeah it's Philly it could be done
it could be done
um and then also exciting news Kelsey
ballerini will be the musical guest that
night because she just put out her EP
rolling up the welcome mat accompanied
with a short film that's like a music
One Long music video for every song on
the EP I think it's like six songs and
it's all about her divorce from Morgan
Evans so
first off like I think a lot of people
are shipping Travis Kelty and Kelsey
ballerini um but it is worth noting when
she posted on Instagram announcing that
she's doing SNL Chase Stokes commented
so I think her and Chase are like very
much they're spoken for they are spoken
before so like I agree like I would
literally live for it but I also feel
like I don't know Travis Kelsey's having
this moment I don't think he wants to be
bogged down I don't think they're each
other's types
I would agree with that too
um
so to the album I was really first of
all like I was kind of quaking because
Kelsey really didn't say much about the
divorce publicly or in her most recent
album heart first which is amazing
um subject to change oh sorry subject to
change yeah heart versus the single but
Morgan did Morgan Had performed a song
at like a show in Australia and people
really responded to it so he recorded it
like the live version and put it out
it's called over for you and it's
actually a really good song I've been
listening to it and I enjoy it
um and basically the the the message of
his song is how long has it been over
for you like I would have done anything
for you took a flight through the night
to be that shoulder for you and like you
just didn't want my shoulder for you
like his song is very much giving like
victim energy yeah so and also energy of
like I was not the one who chose this
yes this was chosen for me right and I
loved you more than anything and I would
have done anything for you and you did
didn't want it so when she opens with
the song that says that's when it was
over for me it's clearly like a direct
response I was kind of quaking there was
a lot of direct response marketing oh I
mean
you got half I was if anybody had a
question he had got half and I just want
to say like the absolute disdain in her
eyes when she said that like agreed
agreed like taking money from a woman
ill yeah um
it was really well done I think like it
wasn't very um
difficult to read she was like being
very honest it wasn't like subliminal
messaging like it was very direct and
clear what happened and she does
corroborate like she was the one who
left but it wasn't because of no reason
like there was a laundry list of things
and that's what she sang about and it's
clear that like she really struggles
with it and maybe she even like feels
guilty that she left but like she was so
unhappy and sorry yeah so no continuing
your thought and then I'll give I'll
Give All Mine so
the the takeaway for me was that like
Hebrew was very much like traditional
and almost in a way resented her career
I had assumed that he resented her
career because like he wanted the same
type of one but what she was saying is
like because he was very traditional and
wanted like you know make me a plate and
let's have kids and white picket fence
and her career was one of the things in
the way of stopping her from doing that
and that's why he resented her career
not out of jealousy even though like
he's also a country artist so I don't
know how any human being could not oh I
didn't get as much of the career
resenting stuff like yes he wanted when
they were playing Monopoly and she got
the career card oh but and he wanted her
to make him a play and it's like she's
busy but you know a plate once in a
while it can be made
um and you know she's like holding all
the dishes so it was reminding me
actually of Casey Musgraves yeah of
course what was it Housewives uh
Breadwinner Breadwinner
um like really kind of the same message
and it's kind of the same story and I so
most of the album is about like her
feelings and how she felt in their
marriage and how she lost herself and
how she felt alone and how she felt like
she was pretending and how you know the
love
fizzled they grew apart all this stuff
and so I felt like that was really
honest I feel like a lot of people could
relate to that feeling but my overall
takeaway was that there was there's no
tea in this divorce like no yeah except
that he got half oh yeah but like in
terms of how like what happened between
them like nothing happened these are two
people who got married young who grew
apart and who also which happens to
couples all the time a lot of people but
like when you live with someone when
you're in it every day and it's the same
thing every single day like you either
things actually either get like really
bad or you work on it but when two
people are constantly traveling and then
like the thing that binds them like it
just keeps getting weaker it's like and
they don't have kids it's like why would
we stay married like we're both no
you're right unhappy and I think both of
them
we're not ever going to like prioritize
making their marriage work over their
careers because they have they're both
extremely talented and they're having
success so like why are we going to come
home to be miserable in Nashville where
like there's things to be done out there
in the world and um also as they see the
world they're getting a taste of what
what could be and it's like why am I
going again to my penthouse to like go
probably pretend with my husband who we
don't have that much in common anymore
and neither of us are really invested in
finding commonality and I think that's
really why like the lack of tea it was I
think that's why it's it's gaining so
much traction from people is because
like most people most divorces are not
these like knock down drag out you
cheated like there's not like sometimes
people really do just grow apart and
that makes it even harder to explain to
your friends and family like what's
going on so I think a lot of people are
like really relating to this because
it's very normal it's not you know
celebrity like what happened no it's
just like you're right two people who
got married really young who grew up
hard yeah and who don't have really any
reason to stay together right because
you know
usually it would be kids or something
and then also kids complicate things
then you have alimony custody issues
um so it's easier to stay together
sometimes yeah but also it makes a it
also makes a divorce more um
tricky tricky I don't think this is a
tricky divorce I think she's just saying
how she feels when I finished watching
this I wasn't like oh Morgan you have
something to answer for no he was just
like upstairs playing his guitar and
like not really emotionally vibing with
his wife yeah
um
okay
yeah I also do wonder if Kelsey would
have ever like released this
if he had it like he started it you know
like he released a song first yeah I
feel like no she did say in the
interlude like you know it's like it's
very much like the industry to blame the
woman
um but I didn't feel like until that
song where he was like being victim me
that there was any misunderstanding or
narrative going around about what
happened
that was putting the blame on her you
know I mean we have a theory that like
you know she's bigger that's weird uh it
was actually not even as interesting as
that well so I'm just like
really intrigued by you know many years
ago a lot of the like big up-and-coming
female country artists all got married
in the same year
and they were all married to people
significantly less
as well but country artists as well so
there was Rustin Kelly and Kelsea baller
and Casey Musgraves who are since
divorce it was Morgan Evans and Kelsea
ballerini who are since divorce and the
last one standing is Marin Morrison and
Ryan Hurd and they have a baby and they
seem to be doing really well and I don't
get those vibes from him like I feel
like me neither Kelsey and Casey it was
always like they're not
physically together no they were always
showing up to like these major career
Milestones by themselves yeah like Ryan
Hurd is really always with always with
Marin and they do songs together and he
always shows up to support her and she
always shows up to support him I you and
that's what another key takeaway from
the short film was like you really never
know what's going on in a marriage but
from what I see of Ryan and Marin they
seem to be really happy yeah and so I
like I thought it was I thought it was
really well done I think the songs are
beautiful I look forward to listening to
them without and I feel like if I listen
to them without watching the video I
wouldn't have heard everything you know
because you get distracted but I was
like laser focused I was like she said
this he did that yeah this is what
happened so I feel I'm glad that she put
out a whole video and I think was a
really cool way to drop an album
um
I don't think anyone's ever done a whole
out album is a short film correct me if
I'm wrong at least not one that I've
seen not a short film like Beyonce's
just lemonade but it was all the music
videos yeah it was it's like a Visual
Album yeah but this is like what uh one
YouTube video 20 minutes yeah yeah I
thought that was cool yeah I thought it
was cool too I wasn't expecting it I
honestly thought she wasn't going to
talk about it really that much but he
definitely started it
I guess so but yeah yeah
I just don't want everyone to like go
and give him a hate now because I I I
don't think no I don't think that's what
she wants either no no but that's what
the internet does you know I know I know
remember like Olivia Rodrigo like what
where's Joshua Bassett is he okay oh my
God have you not heard no
vember he came out as queer yeah
then like a week ago he like had been
kind of Silent on social media and he
came back and was like
I have found Christ I feel so happy and
good and then his church released video
footage of him getting baptized and I
think a lot of people were deeply moved
by it then it turned out like the church
is like a conversion therapy church
people don't know what's going on with
Joshua Bassett and if he's okay he
released a statement being like I didn't
know that they did conversion I really I
don't know but there's a lot going on
with Joshua
to further my point right like we can no
I think about that a lot we cannot take
one person's experience and support them
and how they're feeling and doesn't mean
we have to dump on another
the unattended consequences of like the
the songwriting and I think a lot of
people do it because I think they see
people being really successful at it
like Olivia Rodrigo like Taylor Swift
they make it really clear who they're
talking about and they don't think about
the vitriol that gets sent that person's
way I mean Sabrina Carpenter yeah and
she's a queen and she handled the whole
thing with such class and elegance and
she's really having a moment now her
music is so good but like justice for
her and
you know what like a little bit of
responsibility on Olivia Rodrigo for not
encouraging people to stop yes but I
will also say that when Olivia Rodrigo
put out that song she never thought
people would care in the way that they
did it was just like a young girl like
writing her truth and her diary you know
it's not like she could have ever
foreseen that sort of of course but she
could have she could have like done
something yeah especially since like she
said like he didn't cheat on her he just
like they broke up and and then he
started eating someone else like it was
extremely sad it was extremely culture
she was upset yeah so you're allowed to
write about your feelings
no but that's like the culture now it's
like the mob the mob I've been figuring
it out calm down
everyone seriously needs to get a
[__] life like just because something
is good and we want to support someone
doesn't mean that there's like an equal
and opposite bad person that needs to be
I mean Selena and Haley Selena and Haley
I don't even know what that Tick Tock
drama is I could tell you because it's
literally irrelevant and it's a good
segue into our next story which I think
is about Selena right it will be now
because you're just moving my stories
around today so organic we are
organic so the Selena and Haley thing is
Selena
um had posted a tick tock or or
something just talking about
um actually you know what I don't even
remember what it was but like people
were like coming for Selena for
something like I think it was her uh
appearance and then totally separate uh
Haley Bieber made a tick tock with her
friends to that sound
um
I'm like botching the recap of this I
just can't remember
uh
just give me a second okay I don't want
to like you know start something I can't
finish I understand dirty
that's not like you
okay so Selena got body shamed after
wearing oh Selena got body shamed after
wearing a bikini on vacation and then
like a few days later Kendall Justin
Justine Skye and Haley Bieber posted a
tick tock on Haley Bieber's page to that
sound and I'm not saying she deserved it
but God's timing is always right which
is just like a really popular sound I
don't think that like Haley Bieber's
like keeping up on what the backlash to
Selena is of the day and everyone and
then somebody you know a fan account was
like how could Haley post this
and Selena commented on that yeah
victimy Victor me like I don't let stuff
like this get me down like thank you
guys and honestly just kind of
Fanning the Flames like I I think Selena
was wrong for that yeah she is and I
love my queen she is wrong for that
um
it's very Morgan Evans
victim mentality okay got it so nothing
Burger thank you nothing Burger but
something Burger Selena Gomez is opening
up about gaining weight due to her lupus
medication she says I'm not a model and
I never will be in the clip from a
recent Tick Tock live stream that's
since been shared on Twitter the 30 year
old singer and actress told fans that
her taking the medication for Lupus
often causes her to gain weight and vice
versa when I'm taking it I tend to hold
a lot of water weight and that happens
very normally when I'm off of it I tend
to lose weight I just wanted to say and
encourage anyone out there who feels any
sort of Shame for exactly what they're
going through and no one knows the real
story what I just want people to know
that you're beautiful and you're
wonderful yeah we have days where maybe
we feel like [__] but I would rather be
healthy and take care of myself my
medications are important and I believe
that that's what helps me she said I'm
not a model never will be and I think
they're awesome mind you I'm just
definitely not that I just wanted to
tell you I love you guys and thanks for
supporting me and understanding and if
not go away because honestly I don't
believe in shaming people for their
bodies or anything so what she's saying
is
who says who says you're not perfect who
says you're now worth it who says you're
the only one who's heard and trust me
that's the price of beauty who says
you're not pretty who says you're not
beautiful
who says
consistent Queen like she's always been
she's been saying it she's been saying
it she will be saying it I also
appreciate her just slaying it out there
I know you know yeah like I think this
is like the third time like this year
she's had to just acknowledge the fact
that she looks different and I just
don't really understand what it is with
people on the internet I'm not even just
saying like as it pertains to Selena
just like in general we are obsessed
with people's weight like it is so weird
and it's so illusory like why
I don't know I think I think for certain
people like it's just
you know certain people you're just
obsessed with so you just care about
everything about them I know but like
even with celebrities like celebrities
are entitled to like keep parts of
themselves
to themselves so like the fact that
Selena has to get on here and explain
like Oh I'm a little puffier because I
have to take this medication like keep
that to yourself like you look beautiful
you know yeah
it's so moronic yeah but I'm glad it's
not she's not letting it like take her
down I feel like all of that could be so
damaging enough to make you want to stop
taking the medication because it's like
right right
so she's keeping on in her journey and
she's blocking out the haters I have mad
respect for that I do too and just like
being really direct yeah directed
consumer even though she doesn't owe
people that like that's my point you
know like I appreciate the directness
but I'm like annoyed that she even had
to be that Direct that's what we were
saying when she was after the Golden
Globes being like I really like what she
said like on the one hand it makes me
happy the way that she's approached it
but on the other hand it makes me sad
that she had to approach it okay our
next story is actually some really sad
news Bruce Willis's family has
um announced his diagnosis they say it's
relief to finally have a clear diagnosis
of his condition in a Thursday statement
the actor's wife his ex Demi Moore and
his daughters all posted an update about
Bruce's Health on Instagram along upside
a photo of him smiling on a beach they
announced that his diagnosis is that he
has frontotemporal dementia which is
quote painful for Bruce's family but it
is finally relieved to have a clear
diagnosis earlier in the statement the
women said that since March that they
announced the Aphasia diagnosis but the
condition has progressed since then and
now they have an answer in the form of
FTD uh so sad so sad they said that we
just reported like a few maybe like a
year ago now yeah that he had been like
struggling with his health I think maybe
it was
Parkinson's or cancer or no aphasia
Aphasia
um and it's just like a like a laundry
list it's so sad it's also dementia it's
like such I mean all diseases are
terrible but like dementia is a really
really hard one yeah to like see someone
you love just like wither away mentally
it's so sad yeah which has I think been
really hard for his loved ones but
they're all like speaking out together
and have each other and I think they
really
they only announced this yesterday but
it had been really overwhelmed by all of
the support he's such a beloved
actor and person in Hollywood like I
think by people in the industry and also
his fans that
um there would obviously be nothing but
support for him but it's just really sad
it is so sad and like I feel like he's
known for you know his action movies and
being like a big strong guy and like
this is so you know the antithesis of
that so like we should all just remember
him as that guy because I I don't I
don't know if the public will ever see
him again but I'm sure he looks so
different he's retired now um yeah like
he retired last year because the
diagnosis means that he has issues with
his communication and um it's not able
to work but they're hoping that sharing
this news will help others raise
awareness about important issues that
people might be suffering in public or
in private it's so sad honestly like
not that it's like a competition but
there's really no worse disease than
dementia
yeah it's just really hard for the loved
ones right right it's always hard to see
like
someone you love going through an
illness but like there's something
different about dementia like it's so
like you're like the person you love
most in this world is like forgetting
who you are yeah they're just and
they're not there but they're there
right they're physically there but
they're not even at all mentally there
it's really difficult yeah so that was
really sad news from yesterday
um that is sad a great legacy he leaves
behind mm-hmm
are you ready for our next story you
seem like you have something to say I do
thank you so much for noticing my shift
in body language I am ready for the next
story if it is the story that's brought
to you by Legacy box is that perchance
what's going on you know what Legacy box
is a perfect sponsor for this next story
think of the time and money your family
has invested in capturing family
vacations football games birthdays your
wedding recording a lifetime of memories
was a commitment and camcorders cost
thousands of dollars those tapes were
expensive cameras required film so
Legacy box exists to preserve your
family's recorded moments digitally and
ensure that they're safe forever
so Legacy box is the easiest and safest
way to preserve your family memories
Legacy box
is the best way to preserve your past it
is simple it is safe they have thought
of everything it is a mail-in solution
for converting your memories to DVD a
thumb drive the cloud they're bringing
your memories to the 21st century over a
million families ours included have done
Legacy box all of their
um all of your memories are going to be
personally digitized in the USA if
you've got it they can digitize it so
they can do VHS tapes but maybe you're a
little bit older you got a Super 8 film
reel whatever you got they're whatever
you got they're going to make your
memories shareable Legacy box is by far
the company I get the most DMS about
being like what was the Legacy box code
so make sure to use the code you can
send it in when you're ready you don't
have to do it immediately but
you owe it to your family to safeguard
your memories don't let your photos
continue to fade don't become your
family's hero and save them before it's
too late buy a legacy box today visit
legacybox.com toast to shop this
exclusive offer that's legacybox.com
toastlegacybox.com
t-o-a-s-t thank you Legacy box for
sponsoring
Friday's episode Legacy box is a perfect
sponsor
um for our next story because it's all
about Paris Hilton she's on the cover of
Harper's Bazaar this month and she is
dropping the act as the headline says so
it's her memoirs coming out this month
oh right she just had her baby boy and
she is giving her real self her real
self is giving an interview to Harper's
Bazaar obviously over the years it's
been well documented and she's
acknowledged you know there's the Paris
Persona public Paris and private Paris
and I think over the past few years
those walls are really coming down for
her it started with her documentary and
just like opening up a piece of herself
that she never thought she would and
then there's response from all of that
has just been I think really validating
for her and fine and garnering her the
respect that she's always deserved in
the industry so she is talking about
life now life then her journey and I it
was a really great interview and I'm
like so [__] excited to read her book
yeah no I also love that she just owns
the fact that like very much like her
front forward-facing Persona is not her
and I think a lot of people like because
we're so critical of celebrities to be
like she's so inauthentic but like I
love I think the fact that she like owns
it this is very much like a character
she plays makes her so authentic yeah so
there's one part of the interview that
was so funny she talked about how she
like sings her song Lullaby she likes to
sing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star as well
as stars are blind but of course she
clarified the acoustic version of course
of course she's so iconic and I cannot
wait I'm dying to know what her baby's
name is Maximilian it's not Maximilian
Hilton room
Maximilian is like far too normal of a
name
but it hurt I know I guess her name is
unique yeah and her family names they're
not like names that they invented I
guess Nicole is pretty yeah Nikki's
pretty regular regular but like Baron
Connor yeah Conrad Conrad Maximilian
they kind of go old school too they're a
little all over the place yeah they take
it back
yeah but Paris is like so different like
how could she not have been famous with
a name like that and her husband's name
is Carter mm-hmm
this to me like some celebrity baby
names it's like Rihanna's I could never
guess it if I tried yeah and I feel like
Paris and Carter's like is attainable
I know I feel like it's right in front
of us it exists
what is it I don't know that's one that
like I'm excited to find out some
celebrities like I like I'm really okay
if you never tell me your baby name I've
even made peace with Kylie's baby
what's the name air oh yeah I literally
forgot
um but no so in the interview she's
stripped down Paris mom Paris you know
real uh deep voice Paris and I wonder
now if she's going to stay this way like
I don't know if this was just I know she
took the mask off for the interview
there was something in the interview
that just like gave me the vibe that
it's like a new era for her where we
will be consistently getting the real
Powers because I feel like she feels as
though the world finally deserves it I
think back and they finally understand
her back in 2005 like the way that they
spoke about her they did like the Sarah
Silverman jokes that were made and like
the David Letterman when he made her
like cry during an interview like why
would she ever have given a piece of
herself over to the world but I think
since the response to her documentary
she feels seen and heard and like
open to the idea of just being herself
but like it's also her business is to be
that girly girl so I know I don't know
if she could ever really let her go and
or should she or even if she should but
also maybe it's just something she
doesn't want to keep up like now that
she's a mom like your whole perspective
changes and like maybe she wants to be
like the real Paris like she's still
gonna DJ and you know how do you be like
you know
like an open authentic DJ you just like
play a part it's a good point it's a
really good point so I feel like she'll
still she'll go in and out but I think
this is heralding an era where we will
get more of the real Paris like I would
love to see more of the real her like on
her Instagram you know like just like
yeah yeah
be like hey guys
baby Maximilian didn't sleep last night
right feeling tired feeling tired
hashtag tired
so anyways it's a really great interview
photos are gorgeous and the man I want
to see the baby the magazines are having
a moment this month yeah I had to check
my calendar I was like is it September
because they're bringing out the big
buttons yeah they are they're kind of
killing it and who's on the cover of
American Vogue this month
I don't know let's find out
American Vogue
has it come out yet maybe not
Erica Badu the second coming of Erica
Badu
I think it's Badoo
Badoo sorry
um
yeah it's definitely like it's
definitely like a moment for print
it's a moment for print I love that for
them they have industry they haven't had
a moment in many years print has died
not since the not September 2017. amen
sis oh my God speaking of today's my
anniversary I already knew that I'm not
remembering right now Zach and I
remember like we were talking about it
this morning in bed we were like oh yes
baby yes sleep together we sleep
together actually Harry slept with us
for a little last night which never
happens it was so special mommy's neck
is extra broken but it was how did he
fall asleep so he woke up at 4 30 and
that's like unusual for him and he just
like did not want to he didn't have a
poop he checked everything he just like
didn't want to go back to sleep in his
crib so he kept falling asleep and I
would put him in his crib sleeping and
like a zombie he starts crawling up to
stand he was craving his mama he's
craving his mama So eventually after
like two hours of like this that this
that I haven't I helped him fall asleep
and then I just brought him into my bed
so that he would never like you know get
signaled to the that he was in the Chris
he's so Heavenly that's my dream it was
really really sweet a great way to
celebrate the anniversary a hundred
percent it was really cute I would love
that yeah
um well oh so happy anniversary to me 40
years four years strong wow that is so
long I know right yeah but you've been
married like 20 years yeah it's 75. when
did you get married 2017. September will
be my sixth
okay
it's like five and a half I guess it's
pretty nice
pretty cool being married is pretty cool
yeah I highly recommend speaking of
someone who was married our fifth and
final story is a little familial drama
that makes me sad but Priscilla Presley
and Riley Keough are not talking amid
the battle over Lisa Marie's estate oh
no it has been a very tense wait
Priscilla is Elvis's ex-wife yes Lisa
was the daughter Riley is Lisa's
daughter yeah okay as we stated Lisa
Marie's will was being contested by
Priscilla because you know there was
some forlorn business manager but the
way it shook out was that uh Riley was
the soul right
executor right
um because her brother has passed it was
meant to be Riley and Benjamin
so Priscilla now they're not now not
talking about it because we said it's
it's weird that she's contesting like
Riley's role like that's translator yeah
that's just not
harmonious it's a little acrimonious so
we didn't know what was going on but now
apparently it's been a very tense and
heartbreaking few weeks for Riley Keough
and Priscilla Presley amid their battle
over Lisa Marie's estate an Insider
close to the family told Entertainment
Tonight that the grandmother and
granddaughter Duo are no longer on
speaking terms due to Priscilla's
decision to contest her daughter's will
Riley has been mourning the loss of her
mother and his heartbroken to have to
deal with a trust dispute with a family
member Priscilla is adamant that she has
a valid case and she will prevail in
court Riley and Priscilla aren't
communicating at this time but have been
in communication through lawyers
yikes that's so sad so sad
and I understand like both women's sides
you know because if Priscilla feels I
understand Riley's more I understand I
that's what it doesn't say I understand
Riley's more but I do understand
Priscilla's if she feels as though like
her daughters will is not her intent and
and because there was that like shady
business manager maybe there is
something you know weird that happened
but at the end of the day it just makes
Riley the executor like
it's not right that's not that bad
right right I've been seeing Riley a lot
because they've started to promote
um the trailer and the song for Daisy
Jones and the six and I have to say
everything I've seen I'm extremely
unimpressed no I and I didn't even like
the book so I liked the book and I think
the show like doesn't look good I
probably won't watch it because even the
trailer like I can't believe I like the
book this looks like a book I wouldn't
like
I think everyone was miscast I think
except Suki Waterhouse like is so
perfect and but I think the main guy
Camila I think the main guy I think
Riley Keough I think they're all miscast
I do think Riley Keo was a miscast so I
I also hated the book with the intensity
of Ten Thousand Suns and I know I'm like
the only person everyone's like you
didn't like Daisy Jones of the sex hated
um so I will certainly not be watching
so I don't care I'm not I'm not even
feeling like let down you know I thought
maybe if it looked good maybe I'd watch
it but no
yeah I'm sure it will be good because
the story of the book was good and all
that jazz but it's just like the
era the time and place like because it's
based on like Stevie Nicks yeah it just
does nothing for me
like the 60s Vibe 70s or whatever it is
yeah like whatever that groovy groovy I
guess yeah I'm not very groovy no you're
not like I when I think of like the bell
bottom hippie you know round glasses I
do not think of you and I don't think of
you
no for you I definitely think of like
like the 50s like you know women in like
teacup dresses and like Bob's very brave
and to Camp that's what I that's the
decade I think of when I think of you
that's so sweet and when I think of you
I think of gen Z and how you you are
really the face of gen Z she's just
flattering me you guys before the
weekend she wants to butter me up so
I'll come down on her staycation when I
think of you I think of the Renaissance
that's mean because you're
your presence has been Enlightenment to
all when I think of the Renaissance I
just think of like honestly exclusively
ugly people I know you think of like
chubby women yeah I don't think there
was like a beautiful and that's not
I'm not piggybacking off of what you're
saying because you could be chubby and
beautiful and starting a new sentence I
just think like I don't think there was
one beautiful person alive during the
Renaissance I don't know I have no proof
I just I've seen pictures and everyone
is ugly like I just it's it and I think
the Renaissance was a time of like great
you know Prosperity but for me I think
of the Renaissance As like dilapidated
broke down like I don't know why well
maybe it's an interesting Theory but
maybe they were so ugly because they
were working like on their insides and
like you know thinking about things art
literature art Literature Like not
Beauty and looks even though like our
encompasses Beauty too but yeah let that
set that aside we're just like such like
Gallery girls right now we are oh my
gosh talking about the Renaissance I
know it's reminding me of my book
oh sorry we could change the subject
all right well that is our show our
final show of the week we are back on
Tuesday hope everyone has a great long
holiday weekend thank you so much for
listening to the toast of the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so at Spotify iTunes District
public radio iheartradiocastbox all the
places where we listen to podcast find
us the toes leave a five star review
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have a
great weekend and we'll see you on
Tuesday bye love you bye